[Musica]
se c'è stato un giorno fondamentale
nella mia vita è stato il mio
quarantesimo compleanno
esattamente la 8 gennaio del 2009
certo tutti i compleanni sono importanti
però per me il quarantesimo lo è stato
ancor di più e mentre scartava un libro
che mio marito mi aveva regalato dal
titolo pensare positivo io stavo già
cominciando il mio viaggio dell'eroe
però ero inconsapevole
buonasera a tutti e benvenuti a san
patrignano questa location meravigliosa
dove il sociale non è una medaglia da
esibire sulla giacca della domenica ma è
un vero stile di vita
i ragazzi qui recuperano la propria
dignità attraverso le stesse mani con le
quali si sono fatti del male quindi
chiederei un applauso ai ragazzi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e dopo aver letto quel libro io ho
immaginato di poter incominciare il mio
viaggio e quindi ho fatto armi e bagagli
e sono andata in treno per tre giorni a
padova per frequentare un corso di
dinamica mentale lì mi ha accolto una
meravigliosa ottantenne carmen me l'ero
immaginata diversamente una signora di
elevatissima caratura intellettuale
scrittrice di numerosi libri e relatrice
di conferenze mondiali e di fronte a me
avevo una ottantenne di statura un metro
e cinquanta corpo esile capelli
cortissimi brizzolati però occhi
penetranti sorriso avvolgente durante i
220 km da coriano a padova io mi sono
immaginata
questo corso di nir amica mentale e
soprattutto fantasticato però in piccolo
su quello che avrei potuto cambiare
nella mia vita consapevole 40 anni molti
sogni ancora da non poter più realizzare
fu proprio carmen che al mio arrivo mi
guardò negli occhi e disse tu sei una
ragazza che da adesso comincerà il suo
percorso per realizzare i grandi sogni e
quindi ho cominciato a riflettere dopo
venti minuti di chiacchierata con questa
meravigliosa signora levy ha stretto
fortemente la mano e mi ha detto tu sei
e sarai una guida ho ripreso due antiche
passioni
proprio lì in quei tre giorni in cui
avevo deciso di dedicarmi a me stessa in
cui avevo abbandonato tutto quello che
avevo a coriano e quindi con molta
creatività ma anche leggerezza ho
seguito il corso e ho ripreso da lì
i due antiche passioni la politica e la
poesia
dapprima la poesia ho ricominciato a
scrivere poesie come faceva 18 anni e
poi ho partecipato dei concorsi
letterari
subito dopo mi ritorna questa passione
veramente importante che la politica è
un mio amico un pomeriggio durante una
pausa caffè con le amiche
ne ha dato una battuta quelle battute
infelici quelle in cui ti senti male
perché ti dice voi donne siete solite
passare del tempo a sorseggiare caffè
con le amiche
avete presente un abito bello elegante
che ti va stretto bene a questa battuta
corrispondeva a quella immagine li
incontro da lì a pochi giorni
paride il capogruppo di una lista civica
mi chiede di candidarmi a consigliere
proprio coriano io donna quarantenne
nata in un'altra regione
quindi non ero visibile a nessuno ho
deciso di intraprendere la sfida dopo
due mesi sono la prima degli eletti nel
gruppo di minoranza un grande percorso
due anni e mezzo di impegno progetti
ricerca di finanziamenti e lavoro
incessante sul welfare sul sociale
sull'edilizia scolastica bene da
consigliere di minoranza porto coriano
un contributo statale di 390mila euro
tutti da versare su tre plessi
scolastici un contributo mai arrivato a
coriano nel 2011 contribuisco con la mia
squadra di minoranza alle dimissioni del
sindaco di quel momento e da lì parte
una seconda sfida il lavoro incessante
con i genitori del comune di coriano per
salvare i plessi scolastici insieme ad
un commissario che arriva da roma e
taglia tutti i servizi per riparare ai
debiti del comune
abbiamo fatto un grandissimo lavoro con
i cittadini
abbiamo salvato il lido il trasporto
scolastico lame
chissà la chiusura dei plessi e quindi
li ricompare ancora una volta la sfida
più grande della mia vita
i cittadini mi chiedono di fare insieme
una squadra civica e di candidarmi a
sindaco era il 2012 accetto la sfida con
molto impegno
vi risparmio tutte le critiche le
poletti le pole in le polemiche e gli
attacchi personali che mi sono arrivati
in questi non interessano
abbiamo fatto una grande grande percorso
divento sindaco nel 2012 da subito
cominciò a lavorare per unire le persone
perché coriano è un territorio enorme
con cinque frazioni che non comunicavano
tra di loro e quindi ho lavorato per
costruire il gruppo dei volontari del
verde
il gruppo dei volontari per gli eventi
ho sostenuto insieme alla mia squadra i
volontari che animano il territorio con
le feste con l'addobbo dell'albero di
natale e poi i grandi incontri nel 2011
ho conosciuto marco simoncelli ho
chiesto lui un aiuto in quella
situazione
un aiuto per coriano e lui da
grandissimo campione non solo nello
sport ma soprattutto nella vita mi disse
di sì poi marco è salito al cielo e io
nel 2012
da sindaco avevo fatto una promessa come
stessa il primo incontro istituzionale
l'ho avuto con paolo simoncelli lotto di
maggio il giorno della mia elezione in
cinque mesi abbiamo dedicato tutte le
energie per aprire la storia del sic il
museo dedicato a marco che ricorderà
marco per l'eternità
[Applauso]
marco ha portato nel mondo coriano e da
quel momento porta il mondo a coriano
e questo è un motivo di grandissimo
orgoglio
adesso mancano due anni e mezzo alla
fine del mio secondo mandato perché nel
frattempo sono stata rieletta nel 2017
non sono triste sono profondamente
felice perché ho raggiunto un
grandissimo risultato personale ho
conquistato la fiducia delle persone e
questo lo verifico costantemente ogni
giorno quando mi reco in comune quando
vado a fare la spesa quando tali un
nastro per una nuova attività quando
inauguriamo una fiera perché i cittadini
mi chiedono sindaco qual è il prossimo
progetto utile per la nostra comunità a
cui lavoreremo in realtà io sono il
sindaco sono stata e lo sono
imprenditore del mio territorio cosa
vuol dire ho lavorato per creare delle
opportunità
ho lavorato e sta lavorando
incessantemente per non perdere nessuna
occasione per il mio territorio per i
miei cittadini e quindi da lì ho
costruito dei progetti o unito le
persone o unito il pubblico al privato
mi sono sempre confrontata con il
privato perché dal privato bisogna
copiare vuole pratiche da portare anche
nel pubblico e quindi
insieme agli imprenditori del territorio
ma anche a quelli della provincia stiamo
lavorando ad un progetto di economia
collaborativa più pil al territorio di
coriano più pilla le nostre aziende più
lavoro e più futuro per le nuove
generazioni
questo è importante vi immaginate se
tutti gli amministratori pubblici di
tutti i livelli fossero protagonisti e
nello stesso tempo imprenditori del
proprio territorio quale beneficio
avremmo in tutte le comunità
bene io vi ho fatto un esempio concreto
di quello che dovrebbe essere qualsiasi
amministratore pubblico e lo dico con
orgoglio perché io ce l'ho fatta quindi
ogni sogno che ognuno di noi a non deve
abbandonarlo non fermiamoci
io ce l'ho fatta e tutti quanti voi
potete farcela
i sogni vanno realizzati non bisogna far
mangiare questi sogni dai draghi e dai
dubbi interiori adesso tocca a voi
realizziamo ognuno il nostro sogno
[Applauso]
[Musica]